you
call the cops when you see 2pac uncle
Joey here it's [ __ ] Friday and if
you're not grabbing on to your balls
jumping up and down this definitely
something [ __ ] wrong with you you
understand me Labor Day weekend is over
you had a [ __ ] rough week you're
walking around is it Tuesday is the
Wednesday I don't know what [ __ ] day
this well it's Friday [ __ ] time for
you to get your balls get your pipe
polish to helmet then let's make this
fun that's what people do on Fridays
they make [ __ ] we got this tremendous
sativa hybrid blue cookies over from
[ __ ] perennial this will bury me
understand me it's not the [ __ ]
critical mass that's an indica not a
[ __ ] put you down this is a [ __ ]
happiness [ __ ] refill because you get
stoned at the same time you're ready to
rock and roll
I like the sativa I'm as a team as a
[ __ ] sativa man but that's a
team I like you understand and you know
how it's Friday so we gotta start the
[ __ ] day off with a few numbers I
gotta go to the [ __ ] kids school I
gotta go to jujitsu I got a meeting this
afternoon I got a show till after
Hollywood [ __ ] improv eight
o'clock be there or be [ __ ] square me
Tommy Easter D'Agostino are you [ __ ]
kidding me or what
nice very nice
I like getting stoned to the gills on a
Friday [ __ ] morning with you I'm
saying it's very important Fridays and
Mondays I always try to make it to the
periscope because you guys need that
extra [ __ ] to push you off the cliff
understand you need that push off the
cliff you confuse you don't know what
you want to do the ultimate goal today
is [ __ ] happiness that's the ultimate
it's Friday if you haven't paid your
bills you laughter Pam the chick dumped
you your mom don't love you you know the
[ __ ] deal I went through the same
[ __ ] buddy undo you put your head in the
[ __ ] sad [ __ ] no got a big get chest
up have your head up a little [ __ ] them
tilt with your chin pointing up to the
[ __ ] sky and you do your [ __ ]
thing go gives a [ __ ] that was yesterday
this is today [ __ ] Janice Tammy
that's why people on the run without
them if they get stuck and they can't
[ __ ] see the light the lights right
and funny if [ __ ] you gotta
start with a little reef and open up
turn on the light bulb you think for a
while and what's gonna Dale - it'll come
to you the answer you've been [ __ ]
waiting is gonna come to you know like
this you're a smart [ __ ] you
don't give yourself enough credit you
follow the world by the balls and you're
sitting there going it ain't my lucky
day every day you [ __ ] wake up it's a
lucky day that's the bigger that's
[ __ ] action [ __ ] and the script pay
for you to sit there and feel bad the
script says go out and get your dicks up
and pick up a couple [ __ ] yard sticks
on the way you follow me that's the main
thing if you can't put that together
well Joe we can't help you don't man how
many [ __ ] balls we smoked understand
fill it up again here I don't leave the
house my son stomp to the gills I gotta
go put up a [ __ ] Gentile drama now
when they talked the end there she
stupid [ __ ] questions we taste some
the balls are wash they do two shits and
a nice protein shake I had to [ __ ]
eggs I'm ready and go [ __ ] me
neither but Zoop gonna stop me today and
they need a [ __ ] tank to stop you
[ __ ] how's that before
[Music]
little doc the police breathing I took
it right to the [ __ ] heart along he
understand me that's in my bloodstream
I'm ready to [ __ ] go I'm ready a
roller skate with no roller skates
who the [ __ ] does that uncle Joey does
and that's it that's that
I'll check the way you cop suckers to
let you know you're a bad mother [ __ ]
them man how you feeling that most
importantly your uncle Joey loves you
because without me what are you dude I
got [ __ ] nothing I got a bunch of
Gentiles then Oh he said a bad word
go [ __ ] yourself that's the bad word you
go get your life together and stop being
a [ __ ] fake for your [ __ ] friends
and [ __ ] I don't go there no more
it got so commercialized shut the [ __ ]
up swarming [ __ ] I don't lift weights
anymore it attacks my curious tenderness
I just do movement training now okay
good don't come [ __ ] crying I mean
that's movement there right
you know those people they always don't
do that they do something different I
used to go there but too many people it
became so socialized and he's like a big
word to throw you off and you're like
you know what you're getting [ __ ]
dumb about it that [ __ ] what this
is why I get stoned when those people
come up to me talk to me I just look at
him but I and even listen I got a movie
going on in my [ __ ] and I ain't got
time to listen to these [ __ ] yokels
and beside that that said the smoke
another poem by Jung and ladies that's
it you go on there you grab your [ __ ]
nut you do the best that you can
that's what you could do you know don't
let nobody [ __ ] get out
don't let a [ __ ] move Goku fall you
gotta stop like you shoulda stopped
Hitler in Munich understand
[Music]
Thursday Friday Saturday I'm a [ __ ]
Austin Texas best spots in the [ __ ]
world Houston come on down that was come
on down and next the week after that
[ __ ] City for four shows [ __ ] so
nine shows they eat and ask me if I'm
[ __ ] ready that's well that [ __ ]
thought stay black the church comes by
Sunday night I love you too on my order
I guys be careful out there keep your
eyes open don't let nobody [ __ ] with you
have a good day